- So back to why Bill Cosby is going free.
So it's no surprise that
Constand was successful
in the civil suit,
but later the District
Attorneys changed their mind
and went forward with
a criminal prosecution of Cosby.
And during that criminal prosecution,
they used the deposition testimony
that came out in the Constand civil suit.
This was effectively an end run around
the Fifth Amendment right
against self-incrimination.
They were able to use his
testimony against him,
despite the prior promise not to.
And Fifth Amendment rights
against self-incrimination
are incredibly important.
They're so important,
that's why police have
to Mirandize suspects
before they are able to take statements
when they are interogating them.
And again,
this is a complicated issue,
but effectively the Supreme
Court of Pennsylvania says
that you cannot induce someone
to waive their Fifth Amendment rights
against self-incrimination
and then use their testimony against them
in a criminal prosecution.
You can't trick someone
to waive their Fifth Amendment rights.
Bill Cosby is not innocent,
but these rights exist for
a reason and they have
to apply to every one.